although many mcu characters show up
more than once not every hero and
villain gets a comeback despite what the
actors involved might want but that
doesn't stop them from dreaming these
are the actors who desperately want to
return to the mcu
the second season of netflix's daredevil
introduced one of the vigilante hero's
greatest supporting characters elektra
played by elodie young she next appeared
in the defenders serving as an
antagonist to daredevil and his
reluctant teammates luke cage iron fist
and jessica jones while elektra's latter
appearance ended in her apparent demise
anyone familiar with the character will
know that death rarely puts an end to
her adventures at the wizard world
virtual experiences 2020's marvel actors
panel young expressed enthusiasm at the
prospect of reprising her role she said
let me tell you i love this character
because she's so complex and broken
she's got a lot of villain in her and
also a lot of good young also shared how
much she liked working without knowing
where her character arc would end up
marvel television and my experience are
very secretive so from the moment you
start auditioning until the end of a
series you never know where it's going
sadly young couldn't say for certain
whether daredevil's former flame would
formally debut in the mcu anytime soon
before the deal between sony and marvel
made it possible for spider-man to
become iron man's protege there was
harley keener keener was the promising
young inventor who helped tony stark get
through his struggles with trauma during
the events of iron man 3. i'm cold
i can tell
you know how i can tell
because we're connected
however it took six years for the
character to make another appearance in
the mcu and a rather unexpected one at
that he showed up at tony's funeral in
avengers endgame surprising many
audiences who didn't immediately
recognize the teenaged keener in an
interview with ign simpkins mentioned
how thrilled he was at the prospect of
reprising his role he said when they
gave me the call that i was going to do
it i was freaking out and screaming in
the car simpkins also explained that at
the time his return wasn't set in stone
yet so he refrained from telling anyone
about it for fear of things going
sideways of course tony stark's heroic
sacrifice left a huge hole in the mcu
one that simpkins is more than willing
to fill when asked about the possibility
of keener donning one of tony's suits
and continuing iron man's legacy
simpkins exclaimed that he was 100
on board interestingly the time
traveling young avenger iron lad was
also mentioned as an option one that
simkin said he would do without a doubt
you'd be forgiven for thinking that
sterling k brown's participation in the
mcu was a one-and-done deal after all
his role in black panther was a brief
one regardless of its significance to
the plot brown played the role of prince
and njobu the father of eric killmonger
and uncle of t'challa in his desire to
extend aid to marginalized people
outside of the african nation of wakanda
unjobu works with ulysses claw to
smuggle out its most precious resource
the unique metal called vibranium
jobu is then killed after making an
attempt on zuri's life as such barring
any further flashback sequences in
future black panther movies it seems
unlikely that njobu will ever return
however brown isn't averse to the idea
of reprising his role in the mcu when
fans asked about the chances of him
showing up in a future marvel movie the
actor tweeted that he's open to
returning as in jobu saying if there's a
way i would be honored hashtag wakanda
forever
in the mcu josh brolin lent his acting
skills and imposing frame to the
intergalactic tyrant thanos by bringing
the character to life across multiple
films roland cemented his place in mcu
history as one of its most significant
players however brolin played another
fan favorite marvel character outside
the mcu the time traveling mutant called
cable in deadpool 2. since it's a 20th
century fox film deadpool 2 initially
existed outside the boundaries of
marvel's mainstream mcu continuity
thanks to disney's acquisition of fox
and the mcu's ongoing exploration of the
multiverse however it now appears that
pretty much anything can happen and if
comics creator rob liefeld is to be
believed brolin would be delighted to
get another shot at portraying the
mutant gunslinger comicbook.com quoted
lifefeld as saying that brolin was
itching to be cable again saying he told
me he understands how beloved his role
as thanos is but he doesn't look
completely like josh brolin meanwhile
brolin himself has revealed in
interviews that cable's appearance in
deadpool 2 was only supposed to be the
start of the character's journey brolin
told ace universe i don't know what what
you know marvel has in store
but it turned out to be one really fun
movie for me
the mcu's version of the red guardian
turned out to be significantly different
from his mainstream comic book
counterpart but david harper who brought
the character to life in 2021's black
widow didn't seem to mind in fact as he
later told insider he considers the role
to be one of the biggest gigs of his
life and he's certainly willing to
reprise it should marvel ask him to come
back harper simply said i'm down for
more harper even suggested two ideas for
red guardian's next on-screen adventure
in one scenario audiences could get a
glimpse of russia's own super soldier
through a number of scenes depicting the
red guardian in his prime harbor's other
idea for red guardian's return features
him going down the same road elena did
at the end of the film harper said when
he finds out that natasha was on that
cliff with hawkeye and maybe the version
of the story he hears is that hakai
pushed her off or something it's a
moment when red guardian turns back to
the guy he was he now wants vengeance
for her
one of the most shocking twists in black
widow involved an alternative take on a
classic marvel villain whereas the
taskmaster from the comics is a highly
skilled x-shield operative named tony
masters the mcu version of the acrobatic
antagonist is antonia dracov the
mind-controlled daughter of the red
room's overseer general drakov the
conclusion of the 2021 film saw drakov
being set free from her father's grip
after spending years as his
mind-controlled assassin with this new
development for the character olga
kurilenko believes that there's more
than enough story potential to earn
taskmaster a spot on the mcu's roster of
recurring stars in an interview with
slash film kurilenko shared a few ideas
about where the character could go next
she said it's always a danger to keep
away from being possessed and
concentrate on keeping her freedom but
it doesn't mean that she'll succeed at
it and there's always bad forces that
will try to capture her i would imagine
kurilenko added that she'd be more than
happy to reprise her role as she
believes that taskmaster is too valuable
and too skillful for marvel studios to
let go she expressed the same sentiment
in an esquire interview too but
clarified that it's up to marvel to
decide if she is to get another chance
in the spotlight
in past interviews crossbones actor
frank grillo hasn't been shy about
speaking his mind regarding marvel's
handling of his character in mcu films
during a 2021 appearance on the lights
camera bar stool podcast for instance
grillo shared why he was initially
hesitant to reprise his role in avengers
endgame saying and i was a little pissed
off about it because you know i signed
like a
seven
picture deal with them and it was like
oh you're gonna be part of the marvel
universe right and it didn't happen
however grillo has been equally candid
about how much he'd like to play brock
rumlow again whether on the silver
screen or on a disney plus show in an
interview with forbes he said i would
love to do a crossbones series just
because i have never seen a character be
on the screen so little and yet have
such a fan following i have a great
relationship with marvel and the guys
there but why didn't they pursue that
why isn't crossbones somewhere in the
mix grillo returned to voice crossbones
for the disney plus series what if but
by his own admission he'd be just as
eager to suit up himself as he said oh
yeah i often say when marvel calls i
pick up the phone
the connection between the netflix
marvel shows and the mcu has always been
tenuous at best with netflix's series
only occasionally referencing certain
events from the films and the mcu movies
completely ignoring the tv shows still
that hasn't stopped marvel fans from
hoping that the likes of daredevil and
jessica jones could somehow be folded
into the mcu cannon mainly because of
the masterful way in which those
characters were handled for example
vincent d'onofrio's performance as the
iconic villain kingpin made fans so
happy that calls for him to reprise his
role in the mcu never seemed to end
based on an interview with screenrant
the actor himself is just as keen on the
prospect of returning after being asked
about his rumored return in the upcoming
hawkeye series on disney plus dinafrio
said that he so badly wants to breathe
life into fisk's character again should
marvel studios ever grant him another
opportunity he continued i just have to
wait for marvel to ask me i think it's
very clear that i would and the fans
know that i would jump at the chance to
play again i just need to be asked
marvel studios and kevin feige have been
characteristically tight-lipped about
the status of the netflix marvel shows
whenever the question of reviving
netflix's hit shows crops up feige's
answers tend to be much like the one he
gave in a deadline interview when he
said i've been at marvel long enough to
never say never about anything that said
if it were up to jessica jones star
kristen ritter her character at least
would be making her mcu debut as she has
claimed that she'd absolutely just die
to play the tough-as-nails private eye
in an unquestionably canonical marvel
studios production in an interview with
screen rant ritter claimed that jessica
jones really struck a chord with female
audiences particularly those who had
survived abuse she said not only because
it was a great role and she's such a
badass but that character has really
resonated with people in a way that i
don't know who else has ritter added
that she would jump at the chance to
step into jessica's shoes again should
marvel call on her to do so luckily for
her rumors have since surfaced that
ritter might show up as jones on the
disney plus she-hulk series so fans
might just see the ill-mannered
investigator return sometime in the near
future
judging from the number of times
daredevil star charlie cox has been
asked if he will reprise his netflix
role in spider-man no way home it's
probably fair to say that fans are
hungry to see hell's kitchen's greatest
hero make his return while the actor has
been decidedly careful about the way in
which he responds to that particular
question cox hasn't ruled out any future
appearances in the mcu
in fact he has even suggested a number
of ways in which daredevil can integrate
himself into the mcu's version of new
york city in an interview with
comicbook.com cox expressed gratitude at
being able to portray matt murdock and
his alter ego for three seasons of the
eponymous netflix show moreover as a
self-admitted fan of the mcu cox offered
up some of his own ideas as to how his
character can return he said as a fan of
the marvel movies i've loved the little
stuff where they pop up here and there i
love the idea of jessica jones and matt
showing up in the background or matt as
a lawyer advising peter parker that'd be
really really cool of course given
spider-man's imminent legal troubles and
no way home it's clear enough that he's
going to need all the help he can get
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]
you